buonasera sono stefano micelli questa
sera vi parlo di artigiani artigiani del
futuro magari proverò ad allargare il
campo magari riproverò a parlare di
quello che potrebbe essere la
manifattura italiana nel futuro ma
andiamo per passi prima di tutto una
nota di spiegazione di solito quando si
parla di artigianato si parla di passato
di un passato magari ricordato in modo
anche un po malinconico
difficile però che un argomento del
genere possa far parte di una conferenza
da ted o altri format simile a questo
quando noi pensiamo agli artigiani la
figura più più ricorrente l'idea che
salta immediatamente che ci salta in
mente quella di un geppetto alle prese
col suo col suo burattino marionetta a
pinocchio prodotto 38 di grandissimo
successo ma abbiamo molta difficoltà a
declinare al presente e al futuro una
figura che abbiamo per molti aspetti
legato al passato
in più in più di solito quando parliamo
dei mali che affliggono l'economia
italiana quando ragioniamo sui media
discutiamo su un'idea di quello che è il
peso della tradizione italiana del
vincolo che ci impedisce di guardare in
avanti spesso proprio parliamo di quelle
piccole piccolissime imprese che tanto
hanno a che fare nel nostro immaginario
con quella tradizione artigiana che per
molti è anche il vincolo l'ostacolo per
guardare a un futuro più più brillante e
contemporaneo
in realtà lasciatemi dire il nostro
presente è già un pezzo di artigiano
assolutamente
capace di stare nel presente un primo
luogo comune da sfatare è che spesso i
nostri artigiani lavorano solo nelle
piccole imprese in realtà se ne andiamo
a vedere il vantaggio competitivo così
lo chiamano gli economisti industriali
di tante medie e grandi imprese
ritroviamo personaggi come quelli che
voi vedete la mia spalla trovate persone
di grandissima competenza che non
lavorano in piccole imprese
questa è un'immagine che ho tratto dagli
stabilimenti differenze di gucci uno dei
più importanti brand italiani nel mondo
una delle persone che concorre col suo
lavoro con la sua competenza a fare quei
3 miliardi di fatturato che il gruppo
gucci porta a casa ogni anno immagini
molto simili li potremo trovare le
potremo trovare nel mondo della casa
nell'arredo casa nel mondo del legno là
dove si producono mobili ma le potremo
trovare anche nel mondo della meccanica
della meccanica di precisione là dove si
costruiscono componenti per le
automobili o macchine utensili questo
tipo di saperi è oggi uno dei pezzi
interessanti della nostra manifattura
una delle ragioni per cui tante aziende
come nel caso di gucci straniere vengono
investire nel nostro paese non è solo
come si dice oggi heritage oggi secondo
luogo comune voglio stare qui con voi il
lavoro artigiano in italia parla anche
la lingua della innovazione questo che
vedete alle spalle e un signore famoso
molto famoso all'estero è un film
signore che ha inventato una cosa che si
chiama scheda arduino un controller una
scheda un piccolo computer che consente
di far parlare internet i nostri
computer con le cose reali ecco massimo
banzi non viene dal mondo della grande
impresa non è nato professionalmente
all'interno di un certo di ricerca
finanziato da una corporation capace di
stabilizzare grandi investimenti ricerca
e sviluppo nasce da una grande passione
da una grande passione se volete quasi
da da bricoleur come professore a ivrea
in un masters inventa una scheda che
trasforma nel primo prodotto di successo
di operare
hardware e che lo fa diventare un'icona
del nuovo manifatturiero a livello
internazionale così innovano i nostri
peso massimo banzi perché oggi è davvero
un personaggio globale ma ne avremo
molti altri che potremo far vedere
perché oggi questi casi interessanti che
vi ho portato all'attenzione devono
essere in qualche modo preso molto sul
serio perché nel futuro possiamo
immaginare una nuova schiera di
artigiani molto digitali molto
internazionalizzati molto contemporanee
capaci di fare un pezzo importante
dell'economia del nostro paese e in
generale dell'economia tout court perché
siamo di fronte a una grande rivoluzione
che voi vedete ben esemplificata in una
bella copertina dell'economist di
qualche mese fa che ha a che fare con la
terza rivoluzione industriale la prima
verrà ricordata quella del vapore che
nasce in inghilterra fino al settecento
la seconda è quella più americana della
seconda metà dell'ottocento
la terza è quella che ha a che fare con
una nuova idea di manifattura che mette
insieme il digitale il signor al
computer con la produzione
vi segnalo un aspetto di questo disegno
che trovo molto azzeccato da quel nastro
trasportatore alle mie spalle voi vedete
uscire pezzi tutti diversi l'uno e dagli
altri
la manifattura digitale consente di
aggirare cosa importante per un
economista il tema delle economie di
scale produce varietà senza costi
particolare quando parliamo di
manifattura digitale voglio sgombrare il
campo non parliamo di cose troppo
esoterico e soprattutto per noi italia
parliamo della manifattura sottrattiva
che conosciamo molto bene le frese a
controllo numerico e laser cutter
parliamo questo sì il campo più
innovativo di quella che oggi gli
economisti chiamano la manifattura
additiva
in particolare le stampanti 3d che oggi
rappresentano davvero la frontiera della
tecnologia una frontiera straordinaria
una frontiera che promette ma in tempi
molto brevi di realizzare con materiali
e strumenti sempre più sofisticati cose
che fino a poco tempo fa non
immaginavamo assolutamente di poter
produrre in connessione con un computer
cosa possiamo fare con questi strumenti
molto
cose ma una vera rivoluzione si sa se
l'offerta cambia a fronte di un
cambiamento della domanda e la domanda
sta cambiando la domanda sta cambiando
dopo anni di globalizzazione che ha
privilegiato oggetti più o meno
standardizzati più o meno di marca
quello che stiamo registrando in
particolare nei mercati emergenti in
particolare in cina
proprio su questo argomento credo che
varrebbe la pena riflettere soprattutto
per noi italiani che vendiamo prodotti
sofisticati bella domanda oggi chiede
più varietà e in alcuni casi la chiede
soprattutto attraverso la rete questo è
un portale emblematico da questo punto
di vista è il portale t.com che davvero
rappresenta la bandiera di coloro che
pensano a un capitalismo in cui la
domanda chiede oggetti specifici chiede
cose molto particolari e le chiede
reclamando l'identità di chi le ha
prodotte un incontro person to person di
con gli americani per noi tutto questo è
un business per noi tutto questo è una
frontiera è una delle frontiere
tecnologiche su cui investire
sì e voglio rassicurare tutti i presenti
che ci stiamo già scommettendo non
abbiamo in questo senso bisogno di
troppi editti troppi proclami
oggi se andiamo a vedere quello che sta
succedendo nel nostro paese qua vicino a
vicenza
beh saremmo probabilmente sorpresi di
vedere che un pezzo importante di questa
innovazione è già a casa nostra
questo è un bellissimo esempio di un
anello che è stato progettato in
digitale da delle studentesse del
politecnico di torino lo hanno prodotto
sotto i miei occhi
io l'ho chiesto lo hanno prodotto da un
punto di vista digitale lo hanno passato
attraverso questa stampante lo hanno
stampato potremmo dire così e questo il
risultato che è stato portato
diligentemente a vicenza dove è stato
fuso come si dice in cera persa da un
artigiano italiano che mi ha consegnato
il giorno dopo un anello per mia moglie
un figurone
perché la storia e interessante
edificante non solo perché qui c'è una
storia interessante di nuove tecnologie
di giovani al lavoro che sono in grado
di progettare quegli oggetti ma anche
per questo il modo in cui noi mettiamo
insieme queste nuove tecnologie con un
grande
demonio storico culturale che è quella
del nostro artigianato tradizionale e
questa fusione che ci rende unici è una
delle parti più interessanti della
nostra economia è su questa frontiera
che noi possiamo dire molto al mondo
grazie